[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat de france 24 consacrait ce soir à
la situation en ukraine au cinquième
jour de l'offensive russe la capitale
kiev semble toujours résisté pour fuir
les combats cinq cent mille personnes
ont déjà quitté le pays selon le haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés
c'est dans ce contexte que des
négociations entre l'ukraine et la
russie ont eu lieu ce lundi à la
frontière biélorusse un deuxième round
de pourparlers est prévue volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien n'y a
pas participé mais il a appelé depuis
kiev les soldats russes à déposer les
armes il a également demandé à l'union
européenne une intégration sans délai de
l'ukraine les européens qui eux
multiplient les sanctions depuis jeudi
contre moscou et qui vont débloquer 450
millions d'euros pour fournir des armes
à l'ukraine alors comment interpréter
cette aide inédite des européens alors
que dimanche vladimir poutine a brandi
la menace nucléaire que faut-il en
attendre des faut-il attendre des
pourparlers de paix en biélorussie
l'armée russe qui accuse le pouvoir
ukrainien de se servir de la population
comme bouclier humain prépare-t-elle en
parallèle un assaut de grande envergure
sur kiev on va en débattre avec nos
invités ce soir patrick martin un jeune
y est enseignant à sciences po
spécialiste des questions européennes
dont soir merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous anastasia chapeau ch qui n'a
maîtresse de conférences en géopolitique
à sciences po paris présidente du cil
tente du think tank eastern circle
spécialiste de la russie des relations
entre la russie et l'europe bonsoir
merci également d'être avec nous adrien
non joncs docteur en histoire à l'inalco
spécialiste de l'ukraine bonsoir et puis
par skype jean pierre maulny directeur
adjoint de l'iris spécialiste des
questions de défense et de l'otan merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'être ici
sur sur le plateau on va d'abord partir
sur le terrain à dans une petite ville à
oman ce type au mount in six pay arrivé
un petit village à 250 kilomètres de
kiev on va y retrouver notre envoyé
spécial de liver craag gulliver bonsoir
vous êtes loin des grandes villes
ukrainiennes mais la guerre est bien
présente là aussi dans le village où
vous vous trouvez
oui on a l'impression que les de plus en
plus présentes puisque il y a une très
grande mobilisation de la population
locale qui met en place des barrières
des checkpoints à l'entrée du village
juste en revenant de la grande ville la
capitale régionale vinnytsia ce soir on
a été contrôlé très poliment évidemment
mais on a été contrôlé à l'entrée du
village il y a des check points qui ont
été mises en place et b par des
volontaires des bénévoles qui ont aussi
fabriquer des cocktails molotov ici dans
le village ce matin il y avait une
fabrique de cocktail molotov qui se
faisait il est à cette grande
mobilisation ce n'est pas l'unique
raison pour laquelle on sent vraiment la
présence de la guerre ici même s'il n'y
a pas de troupes russes sur le terrain
il y a eu aussi des missiles qui ont je
pense qu'ils sont surtout tiré sur une
base militaire qui a une vingtaine de
kilomètres ici mais en 90 ans habite
évidemment pas du tout aussi intensément
qu'à kiev war qui vous d'autres grandes
villes qui subissent une attaque très
intense mais même ici à la campagne
pendant ton domicile de temps en temps
volley justement un univers vous venez
de kiev quelle est la situation dans la
capitale ukrainienne en ce moment
oui en tant que habitants de kiev j'ai
une application sur mon téléphone qui
ont tout normal me permet d'acheter des
billets d'être à moi et d'autres
parkings des choses comme ça et en ce
moment cette application m'envoie les
alertes quand il ya une alerte qu' il y
à un bombardement et qu'il faut se
mettre aux abris j'en ai reçu plusieurs
ce soir en rentrant de la grande ville
de la région venitia sur la route on
recevait les alertes venant de kef
alerte rouge il y avait il y avait aussi
une alerte pour une ride aérienne je
pense que là il ya la précision que
c'est un avion qui lâchent les bombes et
non pas de l'artillerie tirés depuis
l'un des deux pays voisins biélorussie
et russie depuis lesquelles l'ukraine
est attaqué en ce moment cela reste à
confirmer
juste avant de sortir pour faire c'est
direct il y avait le message qui disait
alerte fini attendre les prochaines
informations donc vous pouvez sortir
donc là on est tenu au courant tout le
temps et on a bien compris que les
pourparlers à la frontière biélorusse en
tout cas n'avait pas abouti un cessez le
feu pour le moment et je connais
beaucoup d'amis évidemment et de
collègues qui sont restés à quéven
certains d'entre eux dorment dans les
abris dans les sous sol des bâtiments
d'appartements et d'autres encore
dorment dans le métro merci beaucoup
gulliver craquant en direct de home
outin si un petit village donc à 250 km
de la capitale kiev jean pierre maulny
on est au cinquième jour de l'offensive
russe qui a finit toujours pas tombée
l'ukraine a affirmé ce matin que la
russie a ralenti le rythme de
l'offensive
l'opération russes ne se déroule pas si
facilement pour pour l'armée russe
oui effectivement ça ne se déroule pas
si facilement c'est parce que leurs
virus est quand même bien supérieur à
l'armée ukrainienne alors les premières
opérations naturellement c'était pour le
pont de prendre le contrôle de l'air si
vous voulez que qu'il n'y ait plus de
d'avions de combat ukrainien en état de
marche des aéroports qui puisse
accueillir ses avions de combat c'est
détruire les centres de commandement
direct c'est la tactique classique au
niveau militaire mais effectivement les
russes semblent me semble piétiner quand
même aujourd'hui
la russie est elle apparaît en
difficulté aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut
craindre dans les jours qui viennent un
assaut de grande ampleur sur kiev on a
entendu les russes accusé les autorités
ukrainiennes d'utiliser les civils comme
boucliers humains est ce que ça peut
laisser présager d'un tel scénario donc
effectivement
dès ce matin elle et de l'ovaire tous
les autorités ukrainiens qui ont
donc fait des alertes tous les niveaux
local national pour les civils de rester
chez eux de ne pas sortir surtout
pendant dlr pendant là où des combats
qui passe à ce que les rues sur les
colonnes des chars et des véhicules
blindés donc hermé russe utilise
commencé justement utiliser cette
tactique qu'on a vu beaucoup aussi
utilisé par exemple en palestine utilisé
des civils en tant que a ensuite main
donc dans leur avancement dans la nuque
rennes aussi aujourd'hui des sumos tant
les rêves les reports donc sur les donc
sur les tirs à part les russes sur les
colonnes des femmes des enfants en train
de s'évacuer et de prise en otage aussi
donc c'est femme de ses enfants pour les
mettre sur les véhicules armées russes
pourra justement les utiliser comme ça
donc effectivement ça compliquera
beaucoup le
tâche pour d'armes et le craignant pour
l'ukrainien pour justement ensuite de
tickets mais ça on va voir qu'est-ce qui
est pour l'armée russe pour l'armée
ukrainienne du coup parce que justement
c'est l'armée russe qui utilise les
civils ukrainienne en tant que comme il
est tant que bouclier non non non je
veux dire celle verte du coup le juste
pour comprendre voilà cette
communication il faut se rendre compte
que tout ce qui se passe sur le terrain
la propagande comment les canaux
officiels donc télé russe il leur
apporte complètement à l'envers ce par
exemple voilà il y à des vidéos et des
as sur le stream tout ce qui est sur le
stream craignant sur les rapports
officiels et aussi des remous dans les
chaudes journées taxe sur l'utilisation
des humains aujourd'hui dès ce matin des
civils en tant que bouclier et mais ce
qui est repris exactement et en tant que
miroir partout les rapports rue ses
portes ou les sources officielles russes
la même chose on a chaque fois quand le
gouvernement craignant publie un rapport
sur les victimes donc parmi les soldats
russes sur les tuer selon oddo parmi
ceux-là russe
le gouvernement russe reprend sa et le
présente en tant que les tuer ou
craignant par les rues les cours de
russe c'est un grand problème pour les
ukrainiens ils ont fait un
demande à la croix rouge pour les
évacuer bien sûr ce n'est pas du tout
dans l'intérêt de la russie de les
recevoir parce que ça c'est un message
concret voilà pour la population c'est
la population qui le reçoit et 7j dresse
du coup en ukraine les corps qui sont
comptés aujourd'hui à plus de 5000
personnes adrien nos jours c'est une
guerre de communication aujourd'hui
entre les deux camps oui tout à fait en
fait on est non seulement c'est une
guerre militaire mais forcément
l'information joue énormément et je
rebondis donc sur ce que vient de dire
ma collègue en effet on a des
déformations des deux côtés les russes
instrumentalisant certaines informations
communiquées par le ministère de la
défense ukrainienne par les organes de
presse ukrainien tandis que les
ukrainiens essaye à un tant soit peu de
faire la lumière sur et établir aussi
leurs propres leurs propres contre
narratif leur contre-propagande donc oui
tout se joue en fait au jour le jour et
il est très difficile parfois de devoir
de lire entre les lignes est de savoir
ce qui est vrai et faux metric martin je
n'y ai voulu à réagir ah oui je suis pas
d'accord pour dire que les ukrainiens
font de la propagande enfin il ya quand
même des agresseurs des terroristes à
vous dire les choses cette édition des
gens qui assassinent des enfants qui
multiplie les raids aériens ils ne font
pas de propagande ils ne font que se
défendre
si la désinformation c'est bien la
désinformation de la part des russes qui
à chaque fois font exactement le
contraire de ce qu'il prétend de faire
comme pendant ces négociations
donc aujourd'hui très clairement il ya
de la désinformation et de l'ail il y à
de la manipulation du côté des russes le
peuple ukrainien est un peuple qui se
défend claude mirena ce qui donne des
informations autant se faire que paix
parce que il y à des messages qui sont
brouillées on essaye de bruit et
l'information du gouvernement et qu'il
craignait pour donner les vraies
informations aujourd'hui qui agresse ce
sont bien les russes qui attaquent avec
des bombes à sous munitions à
fragmentation ce sont les russes qui
bombardent les écoles les crèches et les
populations civiles ce ne sont pas les
ukrainiens qui se défendent donc la
propagande certes vladimir poutine est
un expert en propagande et les
ukrainiens ne font que se défendre avec
les moyens d'information qu'ils ont fait
hier à la stupeur générale le président
russe vladimir poutine a annoncé m en a
l'air
les forces de dissuasion russe on va
l'écouter tout de suite on en reparle
juste après
ministre ordonne au ministre de la
défense
et aux chefs d'états majors de mettre
les forces de dissuasion de l'armée
russe en régime spécial d'alerté au
combat
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il est
sous pression
vladimir poutine pour faire de telles
annonces il ya toute la
croyance que les analyses du kremlin
avec il y avait un footing collectif
aujourd'hui cette croyance elle émis un
test qui prend les décisions bien
évidemment pour toutes les décisions
prises pendant ce conflit c'est petit
même qui va avoir à répondre et après
bien sûr c'est à lui qui essaie de
mettre la pression maintenant sur tout
le monde en même temps montrant par
seulement qu'il est capable de bombarder
la population les villes et cetera mais
aussi qu' il est capable d'aller le plus
loin donc utiliser l'armé nucléaire ce
qui est le plus important dans ce
message c'est que le petit ne dit pas
vers où l'art nucléaire va tirer
aujourd'hui on a observé le passage des
amendements à la constitution de la
biélorussie qui maintenant euros de vian
le pays nucléaires dont il peut servir
ensuite le plaza il ya eu un référendum
en en biélorussie dimanche et qui permet
donc aux pays d'acquérir des armes
nucléaires russes exactement et donc
maintenant c'est à dire que ça peut
devenir en place d'armes d'où les
attaques nucléaires peut te lancer on ne
sait pas où ça va être lancé mais on
sait que pourquoi ça peut être en place
d'armes parce que bien sûr ensuite s'il
y a rita streich il ya le la réponse est
aléatoire c'est à dire que elle doit
donc atterrir elle est le sport par
l'admr poutine que ça va peut-être
atterrir un biologiste jean pierre
maulny il faut prendre au sérieux cette
menace russe dans ce conflit cette
menace nucléaire
ce convoi depuis le début c'est que de
toute façon poutine essai de négocia
s'est négociée en utilisant la force en
faisant pression par la force il ya
commencé dès le début en massant donc
cent mille soldats à la frontière
ukrainienne
en proposant de
traiter et il est passé à l'étape
supérieure
qui est donc d'abord d'attaquer le
donbass puis l'ensemble de l'ukraine
maintenant je dirais menacé d'employer
l'armé nucléaire c'est quand même aller
très très loin parce qu'on peut pas
considérer véritablement que les
intérêts vitaux de la russie sont en jeu
donc ça peut être à la fois du bluff ça
peut être ça peut être un aveu de
faiblesse
également d'une certaine manière parce
qu'on ne menace pas à ce stade d'un
conflit de l'armé nucléaire maintenant
il faut quand même
regarder le ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers temps
effectivement
poutine
a quand même utiliser la force armée
donc il faut quand même vérifier qu'il
n'y a pas de je dirai ce que
j'appellerais de
d'incompréhension à ce niveau là avec le
avec le dirigeant avec les dirigeants
russes vous parliez justement de
négociation adrien en juin une
délégation ukrainienne est arrivé ce
matin sur un site qui a été choisie
entre les deux pays un c'est un
compromis à la frontière biélorusse
l'ukraine réclame un cessez le feu
immédiat on ne sait pas vraiment ce que
veut la russie c'est c'est une bonne
chose ces négociations est ce qu'il ya
une lueur d'espoir je dirais que par ces
moments là il faut toujours regarder les
sports néanmoins le président volodymyr
zelensky l'a rappelé n'attendez les
autorités ukrainiennes n'attendaient que
très peu en fait de ces négociations
il s'agissait sûrement peut-être de
maintenir en tout cas tenir un tant soit
peu gagner du temps pour pouvoir
éventuellement réopéré en tout cas une
une transformation une réorientation des
forces militaires mais en tout cas peu
importe ce qui a pu être débattu durant
cette 7e ces négociations il ya peu de
chances qu'elles aboutissent on va
écouter tout de suite
les chefs de la délégation russe et
ukrainienne
les pourparlers avec les ukrainiens
viennent de prendre fin nous avons
déroulé tous les aspects de notre agenda
nous avons trouvé des points sur
lesquels nous pourrons discuter d'une
position commune et plus important
encore nous nous sommes mis d'accord sur
la poursuite du processus de négociation
la prochaine réunion aura lieu dans les
prochains jours à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et la pologne d'ici là les
délégations et leurs responsables vont
faire part des discussions à leur
gouvernement
[Musique]
les délégations ukrainiens et russes ont
participé au premier rang de négociation
avec comme premier but de discuter d'un
cessez le feu et de la fin des
hostilités sur le territoire ukrainien
les parties ont déterminé plusieurs
priorités sur lesquelles des discussions
sont envisagées les délégations rentre
désormais dans leurs capitales
respectives dans l'éventualité de mettre
en place ces décisions
nous avons enfin parlé de la possibilité
de tenir prochainement un second round
de négociations
patrick martin geniès et c'est positif
qu un deuxième round de négociations
soit soit prévu
alors il n'y a pas d'ultimatum donc ça
veut dire que chacun a discuté en
réalité personne n'est d'accord on va
solliciter les gouvernements successifs
il est vrai que comme vous le disiez
volodymyr cns qui n'attendait pas grand
chose de ces négociations en tout cas à
court terme lorsque vous êtes à pays
agressif et quand vous demande d'aller
négocier avec l'ennemi vous lui demandez
quoi en premier lieu ne cessez le feu
arrêtez vous hostilités arrêter de
s'envoyer des chars et je suis le
président en exercice monsieur vélo de
ski et par conséquent je reste au
pouvoir il n'ya rien dessus parce que la
russie est resté d'ailleurs au cours des
discussions il était dit que les
discussions étaient très difficiles donc
on a abouti à rien peut-être que le
point positif c'est effectivement chacun
va consulter son gouvernement ça veut
dire encore s'y attendre on pouvait s'y
attendre mais très bien mais en faite le
président russe se poutine veut gagner
du temps parce qu il veut continuer les
chefs est aujourd'hui une ville assiégée
il y a eu une des offensives aériennes
multiplier il y a eu des morts civiles
set mais il veut continuer son opération
après il sera peut-être amené à discuter
avec un gouvernement fantoche s'il
remplaçait le président volodymyr
zenasci alors un élément nouveau entre
temps c'est que le président la
république française a appelé les deux
dirigeants il a appelé volume i rejet à
skis et vladimir poutine il se serait
mis d'accord avec la routine pour que
celui-ci ménages des corridors
humanitaires de façon à ce que donc les
civils qui fuient puissent être protégés
car vous savez que les français
finalement beaucoup de français plus de
1000 français sont encore là-bas et
veulent partir donc c'est l'iran vient
d'apprendre aussi la délocalisation de
l'ambassade deux fois l'argent de deux
pièces à hay vif et il aurait demandé à
vladimir poutine également de ne pas
viser des cibles civiles résidentiels
comme ça a été le cas cette nuit donc
naturellement le problème de la dîmière
beauties c'est qu'il dit quelque chose
mais en fait il fait bien ce qu'il veut
il s'est peut-être engager vis-à-vis des
manuels macro ne plus toucher les cibles
civiles et n'en demeure pas moins qu'il
veut continuer ses frappes militaires et
quand vous faites des frappes militaires
à côté de zones résidentielles il a
toujours ce qu'on appelle des dommages
collatéraux hélas anastasia myskina il
veut gagner du temps vladimir poutine
les négociations par les russes
entrepris pendant mai
pendant les guerres avec l'ukraine
depuis 2014 ce qu'on a pu observer
justement notamment pendant les moments
aigu de la guerre en 2014 2015 les
négociations ont été entrepris pour
imposer à part la russie pendant les
moments très durs pour le craindre
justement le mini camp et minsk de
également à contre l'ukraine en train de
perdre les batailles donc sur le terrain
perdu beaucoup de gens est cependant ce
moment là les négociations étaient
provoquées et ensuite les accords de
minsk en plus bon en faisable pour pour
l'ukraine politiquement ont été imposées
dont classe et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
signée du goût en vacances cette
intention bien sûr de les remplir par la
suite comme on l'a vu parce que c'est
pas possible mais justement le
aujourd'hui dans la situation qu'on voit
les russes perdent beaucoup de gens les
gens qui entrent en ukraine la plupart
ne revient pas ils entrent sans
nourriture aussi il n'ya pas des
cuisines qui suivent ces soldats donc
ces soldats par défaut comme une
nouvelle marche et qu'on nous tous trois
fois par jour donc ensuite il ya et il
se lance sur les magasins sur les
maisons pour justement même mangé tout
simplement là aujourd'hui dans des
villes ukrainiennes à part la
communication donc entre les maires qui
deviennent questionne devenus les
acteurs majeurs est très important
localement et il y a les ordres de tir
est tout simplement sur l'auteur donc
qu'ils vont aller pour entrer dans la
maison de quelqu'un ou dans nos magasins
pas les prendre un pain des arrêtés mais
les tirer sur place et effectivement
donc dans ces conditions oui il ya 500
ans de plus de 500 plus de 5000 morts
pardon dans cinq jours c'est un moment
où peut-être on veut gagner le temps ce
qui est important de comprendre c'est
que vous même pendant ses négociations
même après ces négociations vous pouvez
regarder sur la chaîne à public de
médias de crânien qui est financé par la
public en temps comme bbc par exemple
que les les
les tirs mais les 5000 morts vous
parliez de 5000 morts mais les bilans ou
mais les bilans sont pas très claires
aujourd'hui on a très peu d'informations
on a sur le bilan exact le bilan exact
est c'est fait les informations se
trouvent dans mais un tel le
gouvernement ukrainien sort les
informations sur les chiffres ou
craignant sur les chiffres russes sur
les civils et sur les militaires ou
craignant et surtout les militaires
russes qu'ils trouvent est en tout cas
qu'ils peuvent compter tous les jours à
la fin de la journée sur le site de
l'équivalent de bussy craignant
aromatiques et où ils sortent chaque
jour les chiffres sur des deux côtés et
en plus le ministère l'intérieur
d'ukrainiens a initié le site pour
trouver vous retrouvé vos proches pour
les identifier pour photographier et
identifier les soldats russes pour les
russes ce site a été bloqué par le
gouvernement russe il ya une multitude
des vidéos des soldats russes qui ont
son interview interrogé par les
ukrainiens ensuite est donc mis sur
vidéo qui disent là moi je regrette
d'être ici et c'est acheter à l'hôpital
etc il ya beaucoup de communication dans
ce sens parce que c'est rossi plus
criante veulent passer le message ne
venait pas ici
adrien non jouons sur le sur le bilan
exact de cette guerre pour l'instant ça
reste un peu compliqué à chiffrer
écoutez comme ma collègue m'a dit viens
de le dire le bilan provisoire est à peu
près 5000 morts côté russe avec un
certain nombre de dégâts faits sur
les temps que les pièces d'artillerie
bien entendu tout cela nécessite
confirmation encore sachant que le
gouvernement russe a décidé non
seulement de ne pas communiquer le
nombre de pertes on a aussi entendu des
rumeurs comme quoi il avait mobilisé des
crématoriums mobile pour pouvoir faire
disparaître les par les preuve d'un
engagement donc tout ceci reste encore
difficile à affirmer mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que l'armée
ukrainienne résiste avec bravoure et je
pense que l'armée russe en fait en
pénétrant le premier jour de l'opération
a énormément sous-estimé la capacité de
résistance des ukrainiens et cette
résistance pourquoi ils ont sous-estimé
ils ont sous-estimé le le sentiment
national ukrainien oui il ya de ça je
pense que déjà il ya une volonté chez
vous chez vladimir poutine il y avait
cette volonté d'aller avec le d'arrivée
avec prudence pour peut-être voir se
jauger la situation pour éventuellement
mais ça c'est impossible arrivées se
présenter comme un libérateur parce que
le but de vladimir poutine ici c'est non
pas à travers non pas seulement de
conquérir l'ukraine s'était seulement
sauver un pays frère d'un de la
décadence de l'occident qu'il aux
rockets il a parlé de des nazis fier
l'ukraine
c'est encore une rhétorique complètement
injustifiée cette volée derrière la
dénazification ya cette idée je vais
libérer le que l'ukraine de l' influence
néfaste de l'occident avec tous ses maux
et le néonazisme en fait partie il y en
a qui semble gagner la guerre en tout
cas de l'information c'est volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien qui a
décidé de rester à kiev malgré les
propositions notamment des états unis de
l'exfiltrer il a dit non non je préfère
rester ne pas prendre un taxi volodymyr
zelensky qui a demandé aujourd'hui sans
délai une adhésion à l'union européenne
patrick martin génie ça serait possible
écoutez d'abord il faut souligner le
caractère héroïque de la résistance du
président un qui effectivement a refusé
de partir ça aurait bien arrangé les
russes parce qu'il aurait été à ce
moment-là un chef d'état en exil et puis
il abandonner son peuple donc il est
resté il est là il est un chef de guerre
y résistent et la guerre de la
communication c'est très important le
peuple sans que son président est avec
eux il est là
continue à lutter alors pour répondre à
votre question c'est vrai que l'ukraine
a passé en 2017 un accord d'association
avec l'union européenne ça a plutôt bien
marché mais on en était au début de la
coopération ça fait jamais que cinq ans
et dont il y avait un bon début de
coopération et lorsque vous passez un
accord de coopération c'est un pas vers
une future adhésion mais l'adhésion ça
prend énormément de temps qu'à l'article
49 du traité prévoit des étapes pour
adhérer pleinement à l'union européenne
ue savez que quand on adhère à l'union
européenne on va intégrer plusieurs
milliers de règlements et directives
d'un coup donc ça veut dire qu'on
accords portent toute la réglementation
européenne
il ya une exigence politique mais il ya
des examens de passage comme à
l'université faut passer second toral à
il faut remplir des critères de
gouvernance politique l'indépendance de
la presse indépendance de la justice il
faut remplir des critères économiques et
environnementaux et tout ça doit être
vérifiée après ça prend plusieurs années
alors effectivement il est demandé
aujourd'hui une urgence une urgence ai
je cru comprendre que le conseil
européen des chefs d'état le
gouvernement au mois de mars là ce mois
ci allait en parler de façon informelle
et peut-être ainsi politique en disant
oui nous allons accélérer la procédure
d'adhésion de l'ukraine ce serait tout à
fait justifiée mais il faut que la
commission examine les critères il faut
que le conseil européen soit d'accord il
faut que le parlement européen vote et
enfin pour que ce soit ratifiée par
l'ensemble des autres les foudres appelé
tous les états soient dans tout ce qui
est hélas pour le pour l'instant charles
michel avait l'air de dire que ça
n'était pas le cas b et donc voilà ce
n'est pas nécessairement le cas il ya
d'accord politique à voir mais c'est
vrai que c'est un pays qui veulent la
liberté qui veulent se protéger comme
les anciens pays de l'est des années 90
il ya donc une exigence politique
l'union européenne c'est la liberté il
me semble qu'il faudrait accélérer le
processus mais ce sera pas immédiat ça
pourrait accélérer le processus selon
vous au moins l'accélération du
processus de l'annexion donc de
ces accessions du coup à l'union
européenne c'est la décision politique
aujourd'hui par les états membres et
qu'on vous avez évoqué très important
c'est que tous les états membres doivent
donc faire sa décision 1
ce sujet aujourd'hui par exemple
l'hongrie déclaré qu' elle va pas
autorisé le passage des troupes ni de
l'armement par son territoire ni livrer
des troupes miremont et l'ukraine l'ont
grille étant un des pays européens en
allié de la russie depuis très longue
date où la russie et des projets
stratégiques type pacs 2 donc le
remplacement des centrales nucléaires en
droit qui étaient gelés par les
autorités nucléaires angra depuis
octobre depuis donc le mouvement des
troupes mais quand même c'est un allié
historique bien sûr en or ban a aussi un
petit personnel pour poutine donc la
même avec un état déjà ce serait
compliqué et ils sont pas seuls par
contre juste pour revenir sur sur les
chiffres c'est le ministre ce ministère
de la défense qui donne les chiffres a
donc tous les jours sur le nombre des
soldats et aussi de chaque type de à
technique donc qui a et qu'ils abattent
à qu'ils comptent tous les jours et donc
sur mettant par exemple à 8h51 c'est
5300 morts dont un soldat
29 par exemple et les corps hélicoptère
5,91 tank etc etc etc i lya le rapport
sur le site de la défense de l'ukraine
qui repris par tous les médias
ukrainiens aussi donc tous les jours
j'aimerais qu'on reparle à présent
jean pierre maulny de ces bilans ces
bilans ils sont
ils sont difficiles à avoir aujourd'hui
après seulement quelques jours de
confier ce qu'ils sont fiables
on est en communication de guerre donc
en communication guère
longtemps et c'est normal je dirais à à
donner à une image très favorable
du nez au niveau ukrainien de la
résistance ukrainienne est on du côté
russe ou valverde inverse donc je pense
qu'il faut
on a suffisamment de capacités
d'observations satellitaires ou même sur
place pour avoir je pense mais ça ne
sera pas communiquer des estimations je
pense qu'il serait plus fiable sur le
sujet m'a ce qui me frappe pour le
moment c'est que
le la pénétration en fait de l'armée
russe sur le sol ukrainien est quand
même assez faible il s'essaie
d'encercler trois villes
esquisse utilisent massivement des
troupes on en n'est pas certain quand
même et est ce qui est sûr c'est que on
parlait tout à l'heure est ce que
poutine est c'est de gagner du temps bah
je ne vois pas avec des négociations en
quoi il peut gagner du temps la seule
chose à laquelle il peut gagner du temps
c'est en fait dans une négociation
d'obtenir une reddition le gouvernement
ukrainien ce qui naturellement ne n'aura
pas lieu si on prend la question de la
négociation la négociation il ya deux
négociations qui sont importantes il ya
la négociation sur le statut
de l'ukraine en tant que tel et
notamment des régions du nord basse à
partir du moment où poutine a dit les
accords de links n'existe plus on voit
pas très bien ce qu'il a à négocier avec
poutine sur le sujet puisqu'il a détruit
ce que les européens puisque c'était
quand même le format normandie qui avait
valider ces accords ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est la
question du statut de l'ukraine par
rapport à l'otan
ça c'est une question visiblement qui a
été évoqué au niveau de l'otan avec les
européens et la réponse a été très clair
il est impossible mais simplement
impossible en terme de souveraineté en
termes de droit international de donner
satisfaction à vladimir poutine
maintenant si on pose enfin si on posait
la question si je puis dire avant le
conflit qui arrivent pas une majorité de
pays de l'otan pour vouloir que
l'ukraine on rentre dans l'otan donc
c'était ce niveau là qui a quelque chose
quand même qu'il faut approfondir j'ai
envie de dire
avec poutine mais le problème c'est que
nous ne peut pas négocier et je pense
que le foot il s'est mis dans une
impasse totale parce qu'on ne peut pas
négocier avec un pays qui en a attaqué
un autre voilà il est décrédibilisé et à
un moment le problème de poutine ça va
être comment est-ce qui va se sortir de
cette impasse qu'on peut considérer que
militairement
provisoirement au bout de cinq jours
effectivement il est en situation
avantageuse
en réalité il a totalement isolé son
pays justement j'aimerais qu'on
j'aimerais qu'on en parle de cet
isolement de la russie si vous le voulez
bien jean pierre maulny outre
des sanctions financières très lourdes
qui ont été prises ces derniers jours
par les états unis mais aussi l'union
européenne les européens ont annoncé une
aide militaire inédite à l'ukraine ce
week-end on va regarder ça tout de suite
l'union européenne en tant que
collectivité s'engage dans le conflit
c'est l'annoncé faite ce soir ursula von
der leyen
pour la première fois depuis toujours
l'union européenne va financer l'achat
la livraison d'armes et d'équipements un
pays qui est attaqué les etats unis ont
les premiers armes et les ukrainiens
quelques semaines avant les premiers
combats suivis ces dernières heures par
différents pays de l'otan l'allemagne
fait rarissime va envoyer des armes
létales sur une zone de guerre mille
lance-roquettes 14 blindés la belgique
les pays-bas la république tchèque entre
autres vont elles aussi armée les forces
d'ukrainiens se pose le problème de
l'acheminement
les aéroports sont souvent endommagé
parfois aux mains de l'armée russe ne
reste donc que le transport par la route
deux pays vont devenir stratégique la
pologne et la roumanie les voisins de
l'ukraine ça fait quelque chose de voir
partir une belle expérience dans une
carrière dans cette optique des soldats
français se prépare à embarquer
direction bucarest
leur mission dissuader toute incursion
toute attaque vers ce pays membre de
l'otan un petit véhicule de
reconnaissance et puis vous avez ce type
d'engin à mx dispersé ils sont au total
500 militaires français a formé ce
bataillon mobilisés dans des délais très
courts
côté roumain toutes les bases de l'otan
sont renforcés comme ici près de
constantes ça le pays partage avec
l'ukraine 650 km de frontières pour les
autorités l'arrivée massive de soldats
occidentaux et rassurante
la roumanie n'est pas une cible nous
seront protégés et on espère que ce
conflit en ukraine se termine le plus
vite possible
la france a aussi annoncé l'envoi vers
l'ukraine d'armes strictement défensive
des équipements et des moyens
logistiques
rien en juin cette aide inédite des
européens elle peut faire peur aux
russes faire peur
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que les promesses faites
par des puissances comme l'allemagne ou
la france même la grande bretagne
d'armes et là la population et l'armée
ukrainienne en lier en leur dotant en
les dotant par exemple de missiles
air-sol jav l'un qui ont fait leur poids
ce face à face aux tanks russes ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle néanmoins il va se
poser un certain nombre de questions si
on veut rentrer dans d'autres types
d'armement type armements légers alors
bien sûr il ya certains pays comme les
spas et les pays baltes qui serait prêt
à se séparer de leur propre armement
pour paul et livré aux ukrainiens mais
va se poser aussi à terme la question
des munitions parce que l'europe de la
défense n'est pas encore réalisée aussi
bien dans le domaine formelle mais aussi
que domaine de l'industrie et les
puissances européennes ont accusé deux
des gros problèmes de manque de
munitions et alors là c'est cette
question qui risque de poser problème
dans les jours à venir si on décide
voilà d'accélérer le processus de
livraison d'armes à l'ukraine ça va
prendre du temps patrick martin geniez
poutine il a réussi l'impossible créer
une véritable unité d'aidé européen a
sur cette question oui je crois que
finalement il a rendu service à l'europe
c'est à chaque fois dans l'histoire de
la construction européenne que l'europe
est en danger de mort elle lutte pour sa
survie rappelez vous la guerre de corée
en 1953
ça a permis d'initier le processus de
construction européenne la communauté
européenne de défense en 54 même si
celle ci a fini par échouer qui a donné
lieu à l'union européenne occidentale
ligne occidentale et donc et ensuite la
ceca donc ça veut dire par là que dès
lors que l'europe se sent menacée elle
est menacée eh bien il a réussi ce qui
était jusqu'à il ya quelques semaines
tout à fait irréalisable c'est à l'unité
européenne
l'unité européenne est une révolution
sur cette question de défense de des
forces une révolution de la guerre
culturelle et politique
l'union européenne accepte devriez des
armes qu'on appelle des armes défensives
excusez moi c'est quand même des armes
létales qui sont capables de tuer ben
c'est à dire on est capable de se
défendre premièrement on les envoie et
des milliers d'armes et pas n'importe
lesquels notamment pour abattre des
avions des hélicoptères donc ça c'est
très important et deuxièmement surtout
une évolution considérable
c'est la politique allemande qui était
jusqu'à présent très hostile pour
envoyer des armes l'allemagne là tout
d'un coup en quelques jours l'allemagne
a changé son complètement à son fusil
d'épaulé si vous me passez l'expression
en effet traditionnellement depuis 1945
surtout on avait appelé sous vide et
brandt vous savez l'ostpolitik sert la
politique de l'est d'ouverture à l'est
est là aujourd'hui c'est rendre compte
que la russie est un vrai danger ils ont
accepté ce qui est en quelques jours une
véritable révolution politique non
seulement de d'exclure la russie du
système de paiement international swift
et de d'être pour les sanctions
économiques et d'autre part d'envoyer
des arbres donc on voit bien que
l'allemagne en quelques jours a fait une
vraie révolution est effectivement
l'europe est désormais uni pourquoi
parce qu'elle sent que sa capacité de
survie est en cause et donc elle est
complètement unis anastasia myskina vous
vouliez réagir deux événements
importants déjà d'abord l'événement donc
évoquée par le collègue donc sur
l'allemagne est complètement
renversement de la politique deuxième
c'est la décision de euro péenne de
acheter les armes ce qui aussi bien sûr
correspond à la deuxième question c'est
acheter des armes à qui et si on me
regarde autour de nous c'est que
l'allemagne qui vend vraiment les armes
beaucoup donc l'allemagne s'est fait
payer par les par les autres membres de
l'union européenne très bien si vous
voulez que je fournis mais il faut le
payer tous s'il vous plaît pas ça c'est
logique mais après je suis complètement
pas d'accord avec donc mon collègue est
en phase donc parce que ce soit le seul
fait de la pénurie d'armes à part
l'union européenne est sa production
parce que l'allemagne était que même
numéro un exportateur d'armes d'ici
peut-être il y a dix ans avant que l'été
est reprise par la chine donc vraiment
où l'allemand s'est inversée reste en
des cinq plus grands exportateurs
d'armes du monde qui exporte énormément
d'armes déjà donc qui vendent des armes
ça constitue un de ses exports high tech
extrêmement porte en exportant afrique
et l'exportant moyenne rien elle exporte
partout la positionnement donc
historique depuis 81 kg est presque 80
censure n'est pas donner les armes donc
au pays dans la guerre s'est aussi fait
partie d'une partie de l'hypocrisie
aussi de la politique allemand parce que
quand même on a cette position en temps
même que étant des exportateurs des
armes très importante après je voudrais
juste ajouter sur les sanctions
économiques en plus de suivre ce qui est
aussi intéressant d'avoir c'est le dans
ces dernières deux jours c'est le sortie
massif des grands groupes européens du
secteur du pétrole et du gaz du russe bp
cherche à ils ont déjà avancé plusieurs
d'autres entreprises ils ont annoncé
leur sortie des projets extrêmement
important sans autre alternative pour
ces entreprises à vrai dire c'est sont
vraiment massive ses 120 ans qu'on est
en train de voir c'est à dire que les
entreprises se voient aussi adam de la
situation que de la deûle a déjà de
survivre c'est plus possible tout ce
qu'on a tous qu'on en a parlé il ya cinq
six jours que l'europe ou voir que même
compromettre cet intérêt donc échanger
donc pour cet intérêt secrétaire
ukrainien pour ceindre aide financière
c'est plus vrai parce que l'europe où va
bien comme l'a dit le leader de lituanie
que c'est luxe brillants ils se battent
aujourd'hui pour nous parce que c'est
l'europe qui va être le prochain essai
doudou d'où viennent les questions est
ce que nous est ce que les européens ils
ont suffisamment d'armes pour se
protéger et les réalisations c'est que
la très peu de pays qui les produisent
adrien bonjour vous voulez répondre non
non vous avez parfaitement raison tout
simplement je voulais simplement
souligné que oui à l'allemagne c'est
aujourd'hui un des très grands
exportateurs d'armes en europe néanmoins
si on veut parler d'europe de la défense
il faut quand même qu'il y ait une
communauté qui secret et que l'allemagne
n'assure pas à elle seule la production
d'armes on a la france le président me
emmanuel macron s'est engagé un tant
soit peut aussi aller dans ce même sens
or quand on regarde l'industrie
d'armement française on est encore bien
en dessous de ce que peuvent faire les
allemands donc je pense que c'est une
réponse collective en fait au niveau des
livraisons et la fabrication d'armement
vers la l'ukraine qui doit être prise
jean pierre maulny ces armes promise par
les européens et ce qu'elles peuvent
justement être acheminés assez
rapidement en ukraine pour que ce soit
efficace
si on a des gens me dire des armes type
missiles anti chars missiles antiaériens
munitions etc etc oui ça peut aller
quand même assez vite je reviens sur la
question peut-être les questions qui ont
été posées sur le sujet
sur les productions d'armes attention il
faut bien voir que les armées
européennes les a remis en général sont
désarmés qui sont conçus pour le temps
de paix c'est à dire avec des en fait
des stocks de munitions qui sont
relativement limités et là on en est
dans un conflit de haute intensité qui
peut durer assez longtemps et donc
effectivement il faut pouvoir renouveler
les stocks assez rapidement d'autre part
si on prend les munitions en elle même
alors par les missiles antichars ou les
missiles antiaériens évidemment mais on
produit très plus beaucoup en europe 1
s'est laissé des productions qu'on a
qu'on a abandonné donc ça c'est des
questions qu'il faut qu'il faut quand
même se poser et que les européens et
que nous français d'ailleurs nous
commencions à nous placer question de
haute de conflit de haute intensité et
la nécessité de j'ai envie de dire de
d'avoir une base industrielle et
technologique de défense qui soit
adaptée à des conflits qui puissent qui
dure longtemps et qui sont deux des
consuls des conflits avec d'utilisation
de d'armes d'armes lourdes et c'est vrai
que nos
nos industries ne sont pas
nécessairement conçu pour pour ce type
de conflit dont il va falloir revoir
tout ça patrick martin géniez vous
voulez réagir oui je veux dire que
l'europe de la défense malheureusement
n'existe pas on n'en est qu'au début
macron mais il a tout à fait raison il a
créé françois hollande avait fait
emmanuel macron a continué la cré est ce
qu'on appelle un fonds européen de
défense mais pour quoi faire pour
essayer de coordonner les commandes
militaires pour faire des avions communs
des drones communs entre la france et
l'allemagne mais nous avons chacun des
champions nationaux qui ne veulent pas
abandonner leur puissance commerciale et
technologique donc l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement de
renforcer la coopération en matière
d'armement si nous voulions une
véritable europe de la défense il
faudrait réformer les traités en
revanche ce qu'il est possible de faire
et me donnerais macron a tout à fait
raison sur ce point s'est renforcé ce
qu'on appelle la boussole stratégique
vous savez c'est le nouveau concept
européen mieux renforcer une capacité
d'autonomie stratégique peut-être un
commandement disons plus plus fort pour
savoir ce que nous voulons mais
évidemment que la dissuasion reste entre
les mains de chacun des états alors que
jusqu'à présent ça a été soulignée à
aucun moment l'allemagne ne voulait
intervenir sur un terrain extérieur on
l'a bien vu dans le sahel si vous voulez
donc c'est vrai que là sur ce point
c'est important mais il faut réfléchir
désormais l'europe se réveille avec cet
exploit cet achat s exporter cette
exploitation d'armement je dirais que
cette salutaire c'est pourquoi l'europe
se réveille là là maintenant sur sur
cette guerre en ukraine elle avait
d'autres occasions de le faire avant il
se réveille parce que déjà deux choses
déjà parce que est cependant très bien
conscience que poutine ne fait pas de
bla fsa on a on en doute et il est une
semaine aujourd'hui on se doute plus et
se prend bien conscience que l être
proche de la russie pour venir pour
juste espérer que tout va se finir en
ukraine ou que les prochains c'est la
moldavie et la géorgie
bien évidemment c'est la russie a voulu
manger la moldavie la géorgie et la
pouvait le faire déjà il ya mille fois
déjà en 2008 mais s'il n'a pas le fait
peut-être d'autres plans le poutine a
annoncé aussi donc dans son dense et
demandant son ultimatum du 17 décembre
que il vise bien la sécurité européenne
de la défense n'est pas le géorgienne ou
la moldave et deuxième facteur pourquoi
cette mobilisation parce que il est à la
prise de en science très clair sur la
faiblesse de désert chypre aux états
unis aujourd'hui toutes les discours de
joe biden qui l'a répété à plusieurs
reprises qu'aucun soldat américain
s'était restera vraiment presque en
ouvrant la porte très grand dam
l'admirent potier en huit ans en entrant
d'ukraine a ensuite son poursuite de la
désinstallation sur en face de la menace
nucléaire de poutine s'en voit des
signaux très clairs à berlin et à
l'elysée à paris parce que là les
européens se rencontrent ils sont tous
seuls peut-être avec uk peut-être mais
peut-être tout seul tout court et là
chacun d'eux va penser très rapidement
ensemble ça encourage beaucoup la pensée
collective parce que pourquoi s'était
pas fait une défense européenne parce
qu'il est le temps et tout l'argent
était là bas mais le temps donc tout le
monde espérait que con pendant la guerre
froide c'est les états unis qui vont
protéger une fois que la guerre est
devenue chaude les etats-unis ne sont
plus mon pardon dit non en restant en
retrait un des escales option un dernier
mot et on se quitte non je crois
effectivement que la défense européenne
c'est un sujet essentiel aujourd'hui on
a bien vu nous avons eu la crise de
l'aco vide et la crise militaire
aujourd'hui nous devrons lancé d'euros
bien plus forte et on s'aperçoit que
seule une europe soudée on peut s'en
sortir merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre d'avoir été présent sur
ce plateau ce soir pour ce débat rester
avec nous sur france 24
l'information continue